vous a retrouvé la pire partie de tous
les temps jamais discuté par un joueur
titré c'est du Bullet mais regardez il y
a quand même 2400 de chaque côté il y a
un et demi e46 c'est une carreau canne
les deux joueurs je vous découle de
développement théorique d'ouverture
jusque là tout va bien et la premier
tournant dans machin comme un coup
est-ce qu'on va le parer non qui est 17
c'est cadeau et ce que je vais mater
désolé ça m'intéresse pas je me
développe juste bon ok je peux le parer
non toujours pas ok je te matte cette
fois-ci non fous des trois on recule le
fou et là le festival continue les Noirs
jouent petit rock il laisse un nouveau
d'un point achète ma tendre un coup le
sketch poursuit cavalier F3 les blancs
ignorent encore le mat pour la troisième
fois d'affilée G6 cette fois les Noirs
dit ok pour finir par le parer la dame
recule cahier des 5 et la nouveau coup
dégueulasse fasciste on vient laisser
les Noirs nous attaquer au lieu de
roquer tranquillement cette fois la
punition va arriver c'est qu'à dame
prend B2 et encore une gaffe double
point d'interrogation tourbéen et les
Noirs saisissent leur chance pour
terminer ce carnage de maths en un coup
raté par deux joueurs à 24